destiny has been out for a year ekti yep
time for new destiny 2 point 0 like my
hearty yep you guys excited you don't
look it I am mad st fans you can play an
all year you'd be trying to sell me on
destiny all year taking Kings just
around the corner tell me what this new
patch this is for everyone right yep
tell me what it what it gives two
players whether or not their get the
taken king or not why you want to go you
want to take it all right I'll start and
then you can fill in do it you've been
playing this morning I played some the
the patch is actually pretty big it's
eight like almost 18 gigs right you
ready for that if you have crappy
internet good luck or even for us with
fast internet it was pretty slow but um
if you've got a bandwidth cap good look
guess so but um a lot of quality of life
I've kind of hearkened this a bunch but
it makes a big difference just like you
I itself is like way better you got like
better questing there's new quests
there's better way of tracking your
quest that you didn't have before that's
like MMO style you can like like kind of
stamp it on the on your like main screen
like okay what do I need to keep doing I
need to kill seven more dudes instead of
going back my options you have 16 bounty
slots now up from 10 so more stuff to do
on top of that let's see what else is
that there's like there's new kiosks
your kiosks kind of house a lot of your
stuff like your shaders um your ship so
you don't kind of have to carry all that
stuff with you anymore you can just like
pick the ones you want and of course
there's new shaders and ships coming and
taking king as well it's a new infantry
system as well in this bad boy um
there's more vault space they've doubled
it which is a pretty big deal in terms
of inventory like like specifically with
gear or what do you mean like I guess
yeah well now you can do class items
which used to be just aesthetic and or
if you won't get to trying to get
reputation for certain factions and a
pvp stuff it would go toward you know
that orbit future monarchy but now those
actually give you defense as well as
certain stat like intellect disciplined
strength and your ghost shell also so um
now that it's nolan north you can call
it i don't know yeah and shell or
something so peter dinklage out nolan
north in and you've been listened to it
this morning both of you Mike what do
you think about his performance I like
it a lot more
I think Peter Dinklage was kind of a
novelty just because it was Peter
Dinklage in a video game and it was I
got so used to hearing him like say all
these lines when you're doing the story
missions that I kind of forgot you know
how good it could be to actually have a
voice actor who's obviously he's long
north as a veteran so he sounds a lot
more like c-3po it's kind of that you
know computerized digital crazy
modulation on the voice or Chris waters
had made the comparison to 343 Guilty
Spark from the ice yeah and it that's
definitely the best comparison it sounds
a lot like that high-pitched you know
like kind of emphatic really happy to be
here and tell you everything but I like
it a lot it's a nice change it's a it's
not as monotone as Dinklage was it's
interesting actually considering the
sort of news over the weekend about the
the lawsuit and how much the story
changed apparently the story was kind of
completely overhauled I wonder if in a
couple years will find out that Dinklage
had like lots of lines scrapped or like
it was a totally different type of
character or something to that end
because clearly like this voice
performance has been done with the
script that we have right now in mind
and in terms of the these will talk
about the question cycle in terms of the
sort of overall changes to you why in
quality of life stuff is this stuff to
think Eric did like destiny fans we're
looking for is this framework like the
list of things that you would have
wanted or are these kind of piecemeal
changes that you're you're happy for but
you didn't really know you want it I
think uh like there are probably some
changes that I'm like oh yeah that's
really cool that I have that like I
don't know if I aspired to have a lot of
these changes but like it's we've had
this conversation in the office me and
Mike about how kind of some of these UI
changes and some of these quality of
life changes are kind of what Reaper of
souls did for diablo 3 right a really
big deal and like you kind of don't
really think about them until you
actually have them and you're just like
oh wow this is like tremendously better
or this is I why didn't we have this
before and you just it just simplifies
things it makes things cleaner better
and then because of that you like it
like the fact that you can turn in
bounties without having to go into the
tower that's a pretty big deal you know
like something like that and another big
kind of change that's going to help
people that maybe haven't played it as
much or even people that have played it
is you can use your ghost now just scan
like stuff in the world and then Dan was
also telling me that when you go into a
patrol mission nolan bot or whatever we
want
call it will actually kind of tell you a
story instead of like dinklage how like
before he's like let's see what we can
do here feel like instead he'll kind of
give you like a small know whether verse
isn't this a bit more yeah then otter
than there as well did we mention we
don't mention the light system no let's
all be changed up as well right yeah so
people that have played a lot of Destiny
liked a you know like to get to 34 or
anything above you know 20 it's all
reliant on light which each armor piece
inherently has a certain above a certain
level has a number of light so true up
until that point it's like a general you
grind XP by completing missions but then
after a level 20 it turns into this you
have this other form of currency
basically so now light is not actually
based off of like certain items you get
it's just it's an average of all your
your total defense and offense so it's
not this stat that's kind of tying in to
your level as much it's more of just an
indicator of how good your gear is but
you know like later on like we're
playing the patch today and a lot of the
higher-level story heroic missions like
hard difficulty we're all you know
recommended this amount of light so now
it's kind of telling you like your
character is probably not good enough
yeah alright this but that's all tied to
just playing more and finding other
things and you know finding quested are
going to give you like legendary rewards
so from what I've played I played you
know a lot of 2 point 0 at this point
just prior to today and it was it
definitely seemed like your time is
being respected more you know like I
think hey and I kind of differ you know
what's your what's your take he loves
grinding cell right you might disagree
with me loves the grind yeah like I mean
he side side point to what he just
actually said that actually I didn't
think about till right now like the fact
that we can't do heroic story now
because of like a finite number of like
I think you have to be like 240 white
study does that mean that like anyone
that does it by taking king can actually
get there cuz we can't get there right
now because it's just not enough yeah
well I don't think way like normal
mission well no I think when taken King
releases in a week that year to stuff
will be enough to get you to lie
regardless of whether you have taken
care or not the patch itself you can get
like better stuff next week right but I
don't know i'm not sure if you can
actually get that stuff from legendaries
so if that's the case that's kind of
shitty i hope that's not well
to get further yeah but um I like in
terms of the grind like that i enjoy i
think i look forward to the raid and i
think this time around having the raid
back after not having in a house of
wolves is a pretty big deal and I think
it'll also help differentiate some of
the hardcore players from maybe some
other more casual players with the
casual players this time around have so
much more to do there's so many more
quests and stuff to farm and grind and
they're trying to reward you mooring and
make your experience kind of more
rewarding like I said to respect your
time as Mike was saying which i think is
fine I just hope that it doesn't become
like super easy like to casual I don't
want it to go like like wow cataclysm
we're looking for raid alright like
press a button yeah and like my buddies
AFK eating dinner I'm like what are you
doing man he's like I'm eating dinner
it's alright like you you guys got this
yeah yeah I got this right click Add on
it just does the game for me yeah so I
don't I don't think it's gonna be like
that it's just that I don't want it to
gravitate too far over I know what
they're doing they're trying to find a
way to find a happy medium of a pc
lomography losing the hardcore and also
kind of getting bringing new people in
casting a wider do you think that like
if you were to like guests at a
percentage of the amount of Destiny
players we're going to buy taken King
what would you say current like
currently yeah they're playing oh I
would say like 80 80 plus percent night
let's go say like 65-70 yeah it feels it
feels like that edge dodos it feels like
at least too late if you're saying like
regular players yeah I'd agree it's
probably like 80 it seems pretty pretty
like monumental as far as how much is
going to change game especially after
next week because you know there's no
anybody who like even if you just spend
your entire time with the game playing
patrol missions you'll hit 40 if you
play enough and I mean they'll take you
a lot longer than like the way Tay plays
or I play but it it's just it's it's
accessible for people that want to just
be casual with it and it's also you know
there's still exotic bounty chains and
whatnot that you can if you want to go
through the grind of that you can get
those like you know specific weapons
everything so from what I've seen from
my understanding it seems like it's
doing good job of like in developing
both kinds of players yeah I think
they're going to get more people to
because like imagine if you didn't buy
the expansions when you play destiny
right yeah you're paying 60 bucks yeah
but you
paying sixty dollars i think i'm pretty
sure you're paying sixty dollars for
both expansions and taking kings so you
get all of that for 60 bucks instead of
like what a wondrous yeah yeah for us so
does that sour you at all no but we've
had this conversation before like I feel
like it's like the time I spend playing
the game for like costs associated great
great for me perfect for me good like
not not a good investment for everyone
like someone that buys destiny plays it
for like four or five hours like maybe
yourself doesn't like where it's going
you stop bad sixty dollar investment I
pay twenty dollars for an expansion I
get two to four weeks if not more were
the content that's plenty of investment
not bad all right I taking king will
have a review up on gamespot soon we
will have a review in progress up on
Tuesday we're going to play the raid
which comes out in the 18th okay so next
this day next week we'll have sort of
you progress hey myself and for other
people from the office will be going at
that okay cool so we'll have to get you
back on next week don't tell us all
about how that one's playing well
probably live streaming too oh yeah so
we also we have running that running bet
what's the running back oh man steak
dinner oh [ __ ] babe I ok just a two of
you who could be a 41st who can reach 40
and what a fatal flaw in his planned
today ok it shouldn't affect it that
much okay well we'll tell us in the
internet will let you know if it's
alright yeah yeah gonna preferred medium
rare just haha what is it what's the
flaw what's the flaw he just has one
more bounty than I do so it's like a
little bit more experience I thought it
was gonna be worse than that because
like so the since the patch came out
today I was planning ahead of time but I
didn't plan ahead for this patch and how
the patch actually changed some of the
mechanics of rice so then I kind of
screwed myself but then it turns out he
wasn't that far ahead so I'm not that
worried and he's played it already
technically hmm a little bit so I that's
why no problem medium rare over you both
like medium rare my choice by tues
medium rare is all right should have
them ready for that right we're on the
cusp of 40 yeah they're a very agrees
yeah all right maybe we'll have medium
rare steak on the lobby and next week
thanks so much for joining us folks at
gentleman and you guys watching at home
let us know what you think of destiny to
point over the patch have you downloaded
it is it still downloading are you not
watching this right now so you get an
extra bandwidth and play some more God
and destiny and they're gonna pick up to
take King let us know in the comments
below